miranda lambert is Carrie Underwood's
biggest cheerleader in her campaign to
win samia's biggest prize Entertainer of
the Year
yeah Underwood is nominated alongside
Keith Urban Eric Church Garth Brooks and
Chris Stapleton at the November 13 CMA
Awards Underwood is also hosting the
show alongside special guest host is so
amazing Dolly Parton and Reba McEntire
no one asked my two cents pretty quick
and here's why it's not about it
actually has nothing to do with the
female flag phrasing right now honestly
it has to do with I've it's been heavy
on my heart because I am on an Oracle
tour and so she there's so much that
goes into it and to me entertainer of
the year I've never won it but I always
look for who should win it based on what
they've done that you're for country
music how they've represented country
music and their art in their image for
that year and if you put all the
nominees I'm a huge fan of everyone in
the category huge fan but if you think
about someone who hosted the CMAs
pregnant and then started an all-female
tour and then had a baby and they went
right back on the road three months
later she has a brand her Kelly about
Carrie Underwood and it lifts up women
she does Monday Night Football and I
just feel like as a whole Entertainer of
the Year should be someone that
entertains in all facets of music and
she has 9 million followers on social
media and she really engages with her
fans and I feel like that to me is my
entertainment of the year male or female
hmm that's cool good showing each other
support like to ask away I'm going to
line up high Arriba can't wait to watch
that I just yeah I think it's absolutely
true like when you are at the top of
your game and both those ladies are to
support each other I think that's
awesome but not just support like oh
love her like actually saying no I want
her to take this it's pretty amazing
okay so we're definitely getting some
comments here Haley's saying I love her
music Jeffery thing she wins a lot I
think someone else should win that's
interesting
she is there campaigning for the one
thing that she kind of wants to check
off her list yeah entertainer of the
year and to be perfectly I mean this the
new album is really great yeah right her
songs are always really quick oh good
why not that's terrific that's a good
time Shay's and Carrie is freaking
Wonder Woman
and I kind of agree you remember - she
hurt herself
don't do that whole rehabilitation and
it's like any bad thing happened like
she just went right back in just
pregnant like what again she believes in
yeah yes so good and Haley thank go
Carrie Underwood